العسكر للسكنات والاحزاب للانتخابات
السوداني عبد الفتاح البرهان اعاده تسليم
السلطه للمدنيين بعد نحو عامنا على
الانقلاب الذي قاده ضد السلطات الانتقاليه
حينها والاطاحه بقوى الحريه والتغيير
هذا الامر
يجب ان يصاحبه خروج القوى السياسيه من
المشاركه في مرحله انتقاليه
استجابه لمطلب الثوار
الحريه والتغيير سلم السلطه لمده عامين
للمدنيين ليتم من بعدها اجراء انتخبائته
خلال لها يبدا العمل على اصلاح الجيش
وتحويله الى مؤسسه دستوريه بالاضافه الى
بناء دوله ديمقراطيه وعادله خطوه لمعالجه
الاخطاء السياسيه
لمعالج الاخطاء السياسيه
ومعالجه الاختلالات اختلالات الدوله وبناء
دوله العداله
الذين جاءوا خصيصا الى القصر الرئاسي في
الخرطوم لم يقنع الشارع السودانيه
في السودان لقد ترحيبا واسعا من قبل الامم
المتحده وفرنسا والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه والمملكه المتحده والامارات
والسعوديه